bonsoir à tout ce nous sommes le
mercredi 6 juillet vous regardez le 7 8
le journal merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition comme chaque jour
nous revenons sur votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités
mais c'est également des journalistes de
la rédaction tout de suite on commence
avec le sommaire après le comité
interministériel à l'égalité et la
citoyenneté du 26 octobre 2015 qui s'est
déroulée aux mureaux dans les yvelines
des délégués du gouvernement ont été
nommés dans 12 villes de france leur
rôle mobiliser de manière coordonnée
l'ensemble des dispositifs d'appui au
développement des quartiers et à
l'amélioration du cadre de vie des
habitants
olivier avant d'arette est nommé délégué
du gouvernement il est notre invité ce
soir
la réhabilitation de la résidence renoir
à trappes est en plein mouvement un
projet innovant d'inhalation thermique
et grâce au bois qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre de la convention en russie nés en
2006 et dans notre chronique nous
parlerons des jobs insolites de l'été et
des activités en plein essor pendant la
saison avec et notre journaliste camille
lambert et le projet de la travail est
considéré comme adopté en nouvelle
lecture à l'assemblée nationale faute de
dépôt d'une motion de censure dans le
délai de 24 heures imparties cela a été
annoncé officiellement ce mercredi par
claude bartolone après les questions au
gouvernement
le texte va désormais repartir au sénat
la droite majoritaire
il envisage une motion de procédure
permettant un rejet du texte sans débat
sur les amendements
le projet de loi porte et je le rappelle
par la ministre du travail et myriam el
khomri reviendra ensuite une troisième
fois devant l'assemblée qui aura donc le
dernier mot pour une adoption définitive
le 20 juillet avant la trêve
parlementaire estivale
le gouvernement aura la possibilité si
nécessaire de faire encore jouer
l'article 49 propre 49,3 pardon pour
forcer l'adoption par les députés sion
et nous commençons ce journal avec notre
entretien nous recevons ce soir olivier
wanda rebond sera vous je remercie
d'avoir accepté à notre invitation vous
venez d'être
nommé délégué du gouvernement attrape
alors patrice scanner ministre de la
ville de la jeunesse et des sports
hélène geoffroy secrétaire d'état
chargée de la ville ont officiellement
lancé le 20 juin 2016 ce dispositif et
des délégués du gouvernement 12 communes
sont concernées dont trappe alors ce
poste est une nouveauté
il vient d'être créé ce que vous venez
respecté quelles vont être vos missions
alors chaque des gouvernements à une
mission particulière un périmètre pour
trappe il s'agit de la chaîne éducative
qui commence on va dire l'arrivée de
l'enfant sur trappe jusqu'à son
insertion professionnelle
donc il s'agit de pouvoir travailler sur
cette chaîne éducative avec l'ensemble
des acteurs l'éducation nationale mais
geof mais pas seulement lançons des
partenaires la ville les associations et
l'ensemble de ses résultats avec l'idée
de pouvoir améliorer la réussite de
chaque jeune son théâtre
alors concrètement comment cela va se
passer est-ce que voilà vous avez
détecté peut-être un jeune avec il ya
des difficultés le suivre alertés les
associations comment pourrait se
dérouler en fait alors déjà il se passe
des tas de choses sur le territoire j'y
suis depuis quinze jours et on sent
véritablement mobilisation et
l'engagement de tous les acteurs
malgré tout il ya encore des noeuds des
situations où des jeunes peuvent être
des décrocheurs peuvent être en
difficulté qui peuvent être à des moment
donné de leur vie en situation de
fragilité
il s'agit d'abord de faire un diagnostic
de pouvoir observer ensemble ce qui peut
relever de difficultés et ensuite après
ce diagnostic il ya une feuille de route
avec des objectifs avec des réalisations
visibles qui parce que on sera ensemble
avec les acteurs concernés devraient
permettre en tout cas c'est l'objectif
est je crois une véritable amélioration
des objectifs clairement définis
on peut pas définir des objectifs hors
sol mes objectifs sont liées à des
soupçons fable des observable à des
situations qui seront liés au diagnostic
depuis je suis arrivé j'ai rencontré une
quinzaine de directeur d'école tous les
chefs d'établissement de collèges lycées
l'inspecteur d'académie le recteur j'ai
rencontré des habitants
je ne suis qu'au début d'un chemin qui
qui se déroulera jusqu'à la fin du mois
de juillet qui nous permettra avec
évidemment l'ensemble des autres acteurs
ils sont importants l'investissement de
la ville est notable est considérable
les associations de pouvoir le regarder
là où les situations semblent être
amélioré alors comment vous allez à
déceler comment on va vous signalez
justement ces élèves qui sont peut-être
en difficulté qui s'éloigne justement à
de l'école alors ses élèves ils sont
déjà identifiés après par exemple un
proviseur du lycée aujourd'hui me disais
que sur une sonde des lèvres de 17 18 19
ans on n'y arrivait pas et là on a un
bon jeu sur ce lycée en question lycée
blériot
on avait vingt élèves qui chaque année
sortait du système donc là c'est une
affaire collective et donc il faut
pouvoir imaginer que lanson des services
de l'état doivent se mobiliser pour
pouvoir répondre à ces difficultés
c'est pas gagné mais en tout cas
l'ensemble des intelligences de chacun
devrait permettre d'y répondre ça
concerne les élèves de la primaire est
ce qu'au nom de la toute petite section
parce qu'on a des classes passerelles
pour les l'accueil des enfants de moins
de 3 ans jusqu'à pour ceux qui le
souhaitent à la fin du lycée afin
d'insérer paix ou d'un professionnel
d'insertion professionnelle mais c'est
aussi regarder comment cette vallée dans
le supérieur
il faut qu'ils plus d'élèves possible
que sont la voie général technologique
professionnel qu'ils puissent aller dans
le supérieur mais c'est aussi peut-être
là que des tout petits tout petit
regardez s'il y a des besoins d'accueil
particulier pour des enfants en bas âge
alors vous appuyez sur donc forcément le
réseau des proviseurs des autres chefs
d'établissements des associations est-ce
que vous avez des fonds qui vous ont été
alloués ou des personnes voilà qui vont
travailler sous leur responsabilité pour
mener à bien vos missions
alors d'abord tous les pôles histoire
d'argent
l'état investit des sommes importantes
dans le cas de la politique de la ville
la commune investit la coupe de
l'agglomération investi le conseil
départemental investi il faut interroger
les déficiences s'il ya des besoins
qu'ils apparaissent sur des projets
majeurs pour lever des obstacles les
moyens seront présents sur le jeu
travail à la préfecture des yvelines
sous l'autorité du préfet sous
l'autorité de préfète à l'égalité des
chances à la politique de la ville les
services de l'état sont mobilisés ce
comité atteint les salaires s'étaient
tous les ministres qui étaient présents
pour justement mettre le paquet sur ces
territoires est en marche et attrape
alors donc les les élèves qui sont un
peu en décrochage si on peut dire ainsi
ont été identifiés mais ce que les
causes de ce décrochage
elles ont été identifiées ce ne serait
peut-être pas là il faudrait plutôt agir
vous avez raison
les causes sont multiples variées il n'y
a pas un décrocheur des décrocheurs
c'est justement parce que on est capable
de pouvoir identifier cecos qu'on va
pouvoir y trouver des remèdes qui sont
encore une fois je n'arrive pas sur un
trail un territoire vierge
par contre sur des situations il ya une
mobilisation est essentielle de tous
pour des élèves bien identifiés qui
peuvent effectivement être parfois très
éloignés de tous les services publics
alors le dispositif donc avait été
décidée en octobre 2015 après le comité
interministériel à l'égalité et à la
citoyenneté du 26 octobre qui sert est
déroulée aux mureaux dans les yvelines
ne vous voyait aliments
je le premier ministre manuel valls
s'était rendu sur place cela mis du
temps avant d'aboutir
finalement le premier scandale au muros
et des yvelines s'est attrapé la halle
la seule commune qui est appelé ce que
c'est là étrange justement auxois
attrape tout alors il n'y a pas que
trappier mantes-la-jolie également dans
les yvelines
on a délégué du gouvernement halliche
abdellatif qui l'établît latif qui en
charge de l'emploi et de l'insertion
donc on a déjà deux de communes on est
là sur une expérimentation
on tente quelque chose avec un effet
fort un effet levier en effet booster un
effet de deux lions et où on pense que
les choses peuvent être modifiés en tout
cas sur une pas assez rapidement je
pense qu'au vu des résultats des lions
pourront rendre compte et je le souhaite
ce dispositif pourrait être élargie à
d'autres quartiers finalement si on peut
parler c'est un peu là la réponse pour
répondre aux problèmes des banlieues ça
qu'on peut le dire
alors je pense que c'est une réponse
parce que mais en tout cas c'est une
réponse expérimental qui se veut
déterminé un don dont cette volonté de
travail collectif alors expérimental
parce que ça va durer un an pour
l'instant on sait clairement c'est
suffisant pour mettre justement tout ce
dispositif en place à arriver à des
résultats
alors d'abord c'est un non renouvelables
et d'autre part dont la faire vos
preuves allant propres insuffisants
écoutez moi je travaille 13 heures par
jour sur sur trappe
je pense que les premiers temps sont
essentiels dont notre projet l'a conduit
du changement c'est pas le temps long
c'est le temps court je pense que j'ai
rencontré des beaucoup d'acteurs qui
était déterminé et qui avait envie que
les choses puissent continuer et enfin
changer en tout cas on a on a su le
théâtre du trad des gens extrêmement
investit alors le chef donc du
gouvernement avait affirmé lors donc de
cette réunion interministérielle vouloir
compléter l'arsenal juridique français
de lutte contre le terrorisme par une
réelle politique de prévention de la
radicalisation est ce que ça fait gagner
partie de vos missions
ça fait partie effectivement de 2,2 à
travers la chaîne éducative on interroge
forcément le rapport à la république le
rapport à ce qu'il était et en cela le
travail avec l'éducation nationale est
entamée quel va être votre première
décision votre première action en temps
avec le délégué du gouvernement attrape
tout d'abord remettre l'ensemble des
acteurs autour de la table c'est une
première action travailler ensemble ça
sera ma première action pendant l'été
comment ça va se passer vous allez
continuer à travailler ce que peut-être
des mois de septembre il va y avoir une
réunion avec des mesures annoncées ou
des choses déjà mises en place
c'est encore plus tôt pour le dire mais
c'est en tout cas un objectif pour
lequel je travaille dès maintenant
merci beaucoup au lit vivant tarder
devance notre plateau il nous avoir à
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et nous
continuons à parler éducation depuis
hier les enfants des écoles maternelle
et primaire sont en vacances c'est un
test un jour particulier justement pour
ces écoles comme à l'école maternelle
paul fort à montigny le bretonneux qui
nous a ouvert à ses portes manon la base
et patrick jacques de dixmude à ce mardi
à l'école maternelle paul fort la
dernière heure de course déroulée dans
une cour de récréation une pause
exceptionnellement plus longue pour les
élèves avant de se retrouver pour
quelques minutes avec leur institutrice
respectives
c'est à partir de 16h30 que les classes
vont se vider un moment particulier pour
madame negaret la directrice au 1er
septembre et ben je serai retraité de
l'éducation nationale
j'ai fait plus de 32 ans à montigny le
bretonneux dont 26 en deux directions
d'école maternelle
donc pour moi c'est une journée
effectivement bien particulière c'est la
fin d'une passion alors à la fois de la
joie parce que effectivement bien je
vais partir comme les autres en vacances
et puis aussi de l'émotion parce qu'on
quitte pas un métier qu'on a et b comme
ça sans une petite larme à l'oeil
ça sera pour tout al heure 16h30 un
départ regretté par le corps enseignant
de l'école et les parents d'élèves
bah si une dernière journée pleine
d'émotions madame d'égarer part à la
retraite
donc voilà d'où beaucoup d'émotion ou à
jim bien cette dame il m'a aidé beaucoup
parce que j'ai un enfant autiste
il m'a aidé beaucoup moi c'est une
famille que j'ai accompagné pendant
plusieurs années puisque j'ai eu tous
les enfants qui sont passés dans ma
classe
donc c'est sûr que des liens journée
tisser voilà des adieux chargé en
émotions
la directrice se tournent désormais vers
le programme lire et faire lire un
programme d'alphabétisation pour les
adultes
elle emporte avec elle 32 ans de
souvenirs et nous parlons environnement
à présent le premier panneau en bois de
la résidence renoir à trappes a été
posée hier le projet de réhabilitation
des 85 logements sociaux est en marche
géré par logirep ce chantier innovant
d'isolation thermique par l'extérieur
devraient permettre aux locataires de
réaliser des économies de chauffage
importante un projet de rénovation
urbaine qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la convention en rue signé en 2006
william elle pour ce reportage
ces panneaux préfabriqués en bois posés
sur les façades extérieures de
l'immeuble devrait permettre une
économie d'énergie de plus de 300
kilowatts heure par mètre carré chaque
année ce chantier piloté par logirep
c'est un projet d'isolation thermique de
85 logements sociaux sur la ville de
trappes qui s'inscrit dans le cadre de
l'anru le programme de rénovation
urbaine
l'intérêt de ces panneaux c'est
dans un contexte on travaille en milieu
occupé c'est justement de réduire le
temps de
le temps de pose donc de réduire le
temps d'intervention pour les locataires
de réduire les nuisances pour les
locataires et ça permet également comme
il s'agit d'une préfabrication ça permet
de limiter les risques de malfaçons lors
de la pause trois mois seulement sont
nécessaires pour la pose de ces panneaux
l'anru la région et le conseil
départemental subventium ce projet qui
s'élève à 5 millions 200 mille euros
soit soixante mille euros par logement
isolation thermique par l'extérieur va
permettre de consommer moins d'énergie
pour chauffer les logements parce qu'on
a prévu aussi sur cette opération
c'est mettre des panneaux solaires pour
chauffer une grande partie de l'eau
chaude sanitaire
et puis des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
vont permettre de produire de
l'électricité pour les parties communes
de l'immeuble 229 milles euros seront à
la charge des locataires prélevé à
hauteur de 15 euros par mois sur les
loyers une dépense qu'ils financeront
grâce à l'économie réalisée sur le
chauffage le chantier dont les travaux
ont débuté en janvier 2016 devrait être
terminé début 2017 et les vacances d'été
ont officiellement débuté depuis hier
les bâches lyon leurs premiers résultats
les écoles primaires et maternelles sont
maintenant fermés cette période rime
plutôt avec leur peau et vacances pour
certains elle symbolise plutôt travail
et journée chargée pour d'autres entre
emplois étudiants ou professionnels
qu'un me lambert nous a rejoints pour
parler de ses métiers pour qu'il était
est une période cruciale bonsoir cabinet
bonsoir florane un commerce tourisme
restauration l'été est un moment riche
pour les pour l'activité économique du
pays
seulement 56 % des 18-24 ans prévoit de
partir en vacances selon un sondage
réalisé par l'institut csa publiée le
mois dernier beaucoup occupent donc un
poste à cette période c'est le cas à
novo vian dont nous avions découvert le
métier de brewster
un travail qui consiste à préparer les
brochettes l'ingrédient phare du
barbecue
eh bien oui forcément même tous le
barbecue une cuisine qui est pratiqué
par 75% des français
si on en croit un sondage réalisé par
opinionway en 2014
alors l'été c'est donc vraiment une
période à mon câble pour l'ancien la
vente de brochettes représente 20% de
son chiffre d'affaires annuel d'avril à
septembre à l'emploi donc une centaine
de brewster en temps partiel ou à temps
plein en fonction de la météo
un travail purement estivale selon
catherine gaud l'air responsable du
nouveau viande de coignières c'est très
important c'est vraiment donc la période
de noël et la période estivale où
vraiment on fait un très bon chiffre
d'affaires donc en fait tout dépend du
temps qu'il fait l'extérieur
nous on est raccroche à ce faux quand
même est assez dynamique et donc le but
c'est d'aller vite mais de faire des
très belles brochettes
on est vraiment dans le bol impeccable
alors autre ingrédient indispensable
pour un été réussi petit a décidé sur
toutes les tables et surtout dans nos
verres je veux bien sûr parler du glaçon
alors durant cette période c'est toute
une industrie qui est roux pour qu'il
n'y ait pas de pénurie
c'est le moment le plus important pour
les livreurs de glaçons restaurants
discothèques poissonnerie 31 millions de
sacs de glace on sont vendus chaque
année en france
nous avons rencontré omar ait marre il
est à la tête de go glaçons après
plusieurs années d'expérience dans le
domaine
il s'est lancé en tant qu'auto
entrepreneur depuis un an à magny les
hameaux
alors chaque jour il transporte 80 sacs
soit plus d'une tonne de glaçons dans
ces deux camions frigorifiques le
week-end il peut livrer jusqu'à 30
clients par jour
l'été c'est vraiment pour lui la période
la plus importante ça représente plus de
70% de son chiffre d'affaires annuel les
commandes sont moins nombreuses à partir
d'octobre ou novembre en cubes en
paillettes ou en grains la glace se vend
sous toutes les formes pour tenir au
frais un buffet ou égayer un cocktail on
écoute par exemple nous expliquer ce
qu'est la glace carbonique utilisés dans
les bars et par les traiteurs agace
fabricant fait ça gasquet qui était
froide à moi sur saône et degrés photo
efe pas la même avec les mains parce a
brutalement et froide
les tracteurs l'utilisent pour retenir
les pièces montées au des repas pour que
ça après après les débarquer les mettre
dans les verres pour faire la fumée et
aux salles de valeur alors on l'a vu sur
les images la glace a pas carbonique
fait donc de la fumée en étant mise en
contact avec un liquide c'est très bien
pour les cocktails sans alcool bien sûr
qu'elle y est ce qu'on peut postuler
pour devenir les voir de glaçons alors
omar travaille seul pour le moment il
souhaite d'abord faire grandir son
entreprise et surtout s'ouvrir au marché
yvelinois mais si vous êtes dynamique et
que vous n'avez pas peur d'effectuer des
livraisons à toute heure du jeu
ou de la nuit c'est un secteur qui
embauche jusqu'en septembre alors des
pistes qu'ils ont peut-être des idées à
nos spectateurs à la recherche d'un job
d'été alors glaçons ou brochettes ce
sera à vous de choisir merci beaucoup
camille pour toutes ces informations
merci la 100e édition de l'open de golf
de français conclut ce dimanche au golf
national de guyancourt avec la victoire
du thaïlandais ton jahia jay-z c'est le
plus grand événement golfique en france
et outre les greens un village
d'entreprises s'est installé plus de
soixante mille curieux s'y sont promenés
nous avons cherché à en savoir un petit
peu plus sur les retombées économiques
pour le territoire les détails avec
fanny bourdillon et nutella et demi
d'euros l'open de france est une
compétition sportive mondialement connue
mais le tournoi est aussi une vitrine
commerciale pour de nombreuses marques
pendant quatre jours un village
d'entreprises s'est installée entre les
greens
les places sont chères pour installer un
stand mais l'investissement ne décourage
pas les sociétés le tarif de base c'est
3000 euros en fait pour exposer et puis
ça montre justement sur le testing
center une face à la boutique ça monte à
peu près jusque 6000 euros donc voilà
c'est des tarifs pour pour exposer et
après parce que certainement pour une
entreprise c'est aujourd'hui plus grand
événement golf en france c'est la
référence on va dire les entreprises les
marques
c'est l'événement incontournable
aujourd'hui pour rencontrer 50000
golfeur c'est ici qu'il faut être pour
cette 100e édition le village s'est
agrandie pour accueillir soixante
exposants ici à la boutique du golfe la
compétition et surtout la venue de rory
mcilroy permet de booster leur chiffre
d'affaires pourquoi avoir une tente sous
d'abord pour faire pour faire du
business très clairement après on est
ici aussi dans cet espace pour
représenter l'open de france et aussi la
ryder cup qui va se jouer en 2018 pour
d'autres partenaires l'open de golf
c'est aussi l'occasion de développer
leur image de marque
c'est le cas de bmw pour nous c'est
important de proposer différentes choses
donc c'est les 100 ans de la marque
cette année donc pour ses 100 ans on a
amené des véhicules historiques on a
présenté on a deux véhicules historiques
on a ramené du musée
de munich on a également des voitures
plus modernes et en plus de ça on a une
boutique lifestyle on présente nos
produits donc
lifestyle golf est également donc cette
fameuse voiture sur l'eau la i8 rouge et
qui est pour la première fois présenté
en france dans cette couleur des
partenariats qui peuvent rapporter gros
aux sociétés si ces dernières ne
souhaite pas communiquer sur leur
chiffre d'affaires
elles sont 85 % chaque année à
renouveler leur partenariat avec l'open
de france de golf et nous allons finir
en musique jeudi dernier le scarabée la
verrière accueillait danakil groupe de
reggae yvelinois originaire de marly le
roi des mares les choix dont il se
produisait pour les artistes pour l'eau
une association à but humanitaire
mélanie potier les a rencontrés avec les
patrick jacquet de dixmude regarder ils
se sont connus sur les bancs du lycée 16
ans plus tard danakil est toujours là le
groupe marly choix c'est dû régler aux
inspirations jamaïcaine et aux textes
engagés
on peut dire ce qu'on veut après mois
les mots les étiquettes engagé militants
ont fait la musique qu'on fait il ya des
chansons qui sont plus sérieuses sur
lesquels on essaie de poser des
réflexions carrément employons les gros
mots il y en a d'autres qui sont plus
légères parce que la musique ça sert à
tout ça aussi notre art c'est la musique
donc comme un peintre irait peindre un
petit peu les émotions que lui donne sa
vie ben nous ça devient des notes de
musique ça devient des paroles groupe
indépendant danakil était sur la scène
du scarabée le 30 juin dernier pour le
festival les artistes pour l'eau
l'association du même nom vient en aide
aux dogons populations autochtones du
nord du mali
on était justement sur une période où on
se tournait vers le mali nous mêmes pour
le
l'enregistrement de l'album à l'époque
le troisième album qui est enregistré
là-bas les années qui ont suivi moi j'ai
su aller m'installer au mali j'ai passé
deux ans donc on était vraiment dans une
dynamique proche tous les uns des autres
et effectivement on sait on sait on
s'est entendus dès le départ nous notre
mission c'est de leur faire des forages
d'essayer de le retrouver l'eau pure
c'est ce qui s'est produit
l'année dernière dans 2013 et 2014
nous avons développé une ferme avicole
et agricoles grâce à l'accès à l'eau on
a commencé par un forage qui a donné une
autre est récurent la rue résonne leur
dernier album sortira le 7 octobre le
premier single 32 mars est inspiré par
le mouvement nuit debout et c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis et rester
avec nous tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec mélanie poké qui présente que
ce que votre magazine culturel sur saint
quentin en yvelines elle vous dira tout
sur la programmation des salles de
spectacles sur notre territoire pour la
rentrée prochaine
je vous retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée
il